[Music]
the best-dressed stars of a 2018 Academy
Awards first up Margot Robbie a
ravishing in this white Chanel gown
custom made by Karl Lagerfeld himself
and it required more than 500 hours of
work fitting since the I Tania star is
Chanel's new ambassador next gal gadot
whose shimmered in the Siobhan she gown
with a plunging neckline she paired the
look with Tiffany jewels that aquamarine
and diamond necklace is about 61 carats
Jennifer Lawrence also sparkles on the
red carpet in Christian Dior check out
the sequin detailing from top to bottom
zendaya was the epitome of perfection in
this one-shoulder chocolate colored
chiffon gown by Gian Bautista Valley the
21 year old pair the look with
head-to-toe Bulgari jewels and take a
look at army hammer in this burgundy tux
by Giorgio Armani
I like this tuxedo to you very much I'm
quite attached to it Jennifer Garner was
a showstopper in this cobalt blue gown
by Versace fun fact she's wearing over
eight hundred and twenty-five thousand
dollars worth of Piaget jewels mary j
blige looked beautiful in this
crystallized white number also Versace
is this outfit number one that's why she
added $300,000 of Forevermark diamonds
free to borrow those earrings you got to
go to store-bought I borrow them so I
have to take them back
and how sharp is Timothy sha'lame look
and his white tux by BER Lucy
Nicole Kidman was as bland Marissa's
ever in this bold Armani Prive gown of
that romantic boat detail on the
waistline is everything and get this
she's wearing over 84 carats of Harry
Winston diamonds last allison janney of
fierce lady in red and Reem Acra she won
Best Supporting Actress but before the
show started told et there's no moisture
in my mouth that's what happens when I
get nervous
I'm nervous I don't know what to do I
really don't know what to do I should
get some of that there's toothpaste for
a dry mouth but I don't know if there's
some this is a really attractive
conversation we're having the itani
actress added over four million dollars
worth of Forevermark diamonds to her low
[Music]